so this show is about winning it's about
winning it life it's about winning it
money and so sometimes I have to help
you with definitions on winning and help
you with cause and effect on winning
what is it that you so if you want to
reap winning and that's why you come to
me you come to me for that President
Obama is in Knoxville Tennessee and
neighboring city of ours speaking at a
fine fine Community College called
Pellissippi Community College and it
came out in his prepared remarks ahead
of time and it's already in the news
media and so people are already asking
me about it on Twitter that he is you
know likes what Tennessee has done in
that Tennessee is offering free
community college tuition you can go to
Community College for free and he thinks
that we ought to do that as a national
program and people are asking me about
that too which I laughed when the
government says free what they mean is
me there any such thing as free when the
government says free you need to grab
your wallet because they're getting
ready take it you know they're going to
grab it out of something else right so
any president democrat republican any
politician says they're going to give
you something free you need to run for
the hills because they don't have
anything to give unless they take it
from someone else they don't produce
anything government does it they're a
parasite they're a tick on the butt of
the American public and so you know they
don't they don't create squat and so for
him to give you something free he had to
take it from someone else or from you
and give it back to you and make you
happy about that and that would be true
of any president or any congressman or
any governor or anything else so when
the state of Tennessee says they give
out free tuition which they didn't
actually say it that way I'll correct
you on that but they it is I mean people
run around go we got free tuition the
community colleges and the governor of
the state is a friend of mine he's a
good man bill has
and great governor by the way but it's
not free you know where money came from
in Tennessee it came from the lottery so
let me help you with this you people go
in to Community College poor people are
sending you to college because that's
who plays the lottery well I play the
lottery and I'm not poor and I'm talking
about statistical evidence goofball not
you statistical evidence is almost all
your lottery tickets are bought and
lower-income zip codes go to the
high-end the rich into town they almost
sell no lotto tickets I mean think about
you pull up to get gas in the rich into
town is it plastered all over the gas
pump and all over the front door the
place when you go in to pay buy a lotto
ticket no because it's a waste of the
space they're selling something else at
that convenience store because rich
people don't buy lotto tickets by and
large some of you are stupid enough to
still do it when you're rich but most of
you know that statistical evidence says
you're more likely to get struck by
lightning three times and survive than
to buy a winning ticket so you don't
play crap like that it's a tax on the
poor and the mathematically illiterate
that's who plays the lottery the lottery
funds this what happened was the state
of Tennessee so many people are spending
stupid money on the lottery that they
had more than they needed for the
educational stuff in the four-year
colleges so they can't have this extra
surplus laying around so they come up
with the idea of giving you free free
tuition it's not free goofballs
nothing's free somebody paid for it
somewhere so that's that started when I
brought that up on some guy asked me Ben
on Twitter and I just put ello ello ello
nothing's free
even when Obama is doing it hashtag
Obamacare did you notice that people got
free health insurance matures went up
fourfold
dude somebody's got to pay for this even
in communism they have to print money
somewhere geez so then people are going
cave-ins have disappointing you that you
don't believe in education I don't
believe in education
not like some of you do I don't believe
in being stupid and I do believe in
education but not like some of you do
some of you think that when he proposed
that that it's all over Twitter this
morning all on my Twitter Twitter feeds
you people's dumb people filling up my
Twitter feed all morning stupid people
stop it stupid people just leave my
Twitter feed alone because you're in
there saying that educate that would you
rather pay welfare or which you rather
pay for Community College well stupid
people say stuff like that as if there's
as if that's the only two choices we
have to involve the government in
welfare or we have to involve government
in education which one because one of
the two is going to occur those are the
only two choices which presupposes by
the way that the answer to poverty is
education very little correlation with
that because I know a whole lot of
really broke phd's education doesn't
solve poverty let me help you with that
one more time because I need to say it
out loud because some of you people
think education is a silver bullet
because if I just get a degree then I'm
automatically promised a job and then
I'm pissed off because I've got an
entitlement mentality when people won't
hire me because I can't interview
because I'm so freaking relationally
idiotic that I can't even walk through
an interview and I got six degrees
because we promised people that
education is the answer let me tell you
what the answer is it's not education
it's character the highest correlation
between successful people the highest
correlating factor to success is not
education it's character character
involves initiative it does involve
becoming educated but you can educate a
[ __ ] and then they're just an educated
[ __ ] that's what happens and then they
walk around thinking that can't figure
out why they can't get a job and why
they weren't automatically successful
because they got enough sheepskin for
five sheep education does not cause
success character causes success in
character is not just simply honesty I
know poor people who are honest of
course you do I know poor people who
have character I'm not talking about
that kind of character I'm talking about
initiative I'm talking about Drive I'm
talking about ambition
I'm talking about the idea that if it's
to be baby it's up to me I'm not going
to sit around and wait on a roasted duck
to fly through the window I'm going to
get a gun go kill the duck pluck the
duck cook the duck and then I'm going to
eat the duck
that's where duck comes from that's
called initiative that's character
that's personal responsibility I'm not
going to wait on the government or my
momma to fix my life I'm gonna go fix my
life that's a type of character that
type of character we'll go get the
education necessary to win education is
an element of it but it is not the
Silver Bullet to poverty the silver
bullet to poverty is mommy and daddy
live together raise good children who
don't steal stuff that's the silver
bullet to poverty its character its
character it's not education and by the
way that is free because it's a choice
you make it's a decision you make this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you